what is going on everybody welcome to
part 32 of our matplotlib tutorial
series as well as the conclusion to this
updated series in this part we're going
to be talking about is a slightly more
complex version of the wireframe as well
as kind of where to go from here as far
as your understanding of matplotlib is
concerned so first of all let's kind of
clear up some space so basically from
here all the way down to the labels I'm
just going to delete to make some space
now the first thing that I want us to go
ahead and do is we're gonna say X comma
Y comma Z equals axes 3d dot get
underscore test underscore data that's
just gonna give us some test data
if you're curious we can also print axes
3d dot underscore underscore file
underscore underscore and what that does
I've shown it plenty of times before I
can't remember if we did it in this
series or not but that shows like the
location of that file right of the file
that creates this like little module so
if you're ever curious about like seeing
your source code somewhere that's how
you can figure out where it is so now
we're gonna say a x1 dot plot underscore
wire frame and then you can plot the X
the Y at the Z now if you have a really
slow computer don't run this but I'm
gonna go ahead and run it just to show
you and what you should get up is a
graph like this now I record in five
frames a second so it's probably still
looks pretty glitching to you but if you
make this graphic really big you can see
kind of there's like a little bit of
divides here between those things but
for the most part that's almost a solid
graph so there are some elements that we
can change here called the stride so
let's close this and this and we will
add our stride and see stride and our
stride and see scribe we'll just make
them both 5 and 5 and this will create a
distance between the two elements so
with 5 now it's a much you it's you know
clearly there's quite the distance
between these two elements and you can
kind of see more of like what's where
things are actually it's almost easier
to see what's going on in this
than the other ones everything was all
like one big blob but anyway so you can
do that but we're using that test data
because I don't think I think most
people probably don't have like the
required you know data to create a
wireframe like that we could talk about
writing an equation or we can just use
the provided equation from matplotlib
also let's go ahead and get that linked
to to that file so this is the link to
that axes 3d so we can actually head
there C Python 34 and I bring it over
then you got Lib site packages Lib and
then site packages that was MPL toolkits
and then in there it's mat plot 3d and
then AXYZ 3d with an e edit that and
here's your code and then you can kind
of control f get test that takes you to
get test data and there you go that's
the formula that's generating this code
anyways if you're curious so anyways
that's kind of the last thing I really
wanted to show you with matplotlib now
moving forward kind of you know what can
we do from here there's a little early a
lot of options for you there's still a
lot more that matplotlib can do for you
I just really didn't cover it but you
can always go to matplotlib org and the
first thing you should do is there's
examples examples is good there's a lot
of examples but you could a gallery and
you can either click on this but the
easiest thing to do is like full screen
this and you start scrolling down and
like look at the images like generally
you have in your mind what you're
interested in possibly doing or not
maybe you're looking for something to do
or something you can even like zoom in a
little bit if you want to see it better
anyway and then start scrolling down
look for what you want kind of check out
all of the options here this one's cool
cuz it gives you all the colors like
this is all the colors that matplotlib
has that's a lot of colors oh my
goodness anyway yeah so you can look at
all this kind of stuff and it's just a
good idea to get yourself acquainted
they do update matplotlib still so there
are changes that happen so keep that in
mind as well so yeah there's just all
this stuff that you kind of look through
and
see quickly visual examples of all the
stuff you can do with matplotlib then
here's like the matplotlib 3d stuff so
version like we didn't cover the flat
bars or anything so you could check
those out if you wanted and then you've
got like all these surface 3d things
like this and such I'm just not really
sure I don't really have any reason to
ever need those charts so if you do
check them out
those that stuff also you can go to the
top and just go to examples and then in
here it has a bunch of other examples
like animation examples and like you've
got all these animations examples that
are available to you and so you can take
that code and kind of check it out
you've got API examples so for all the
api's that they have they do they have
like a finance API for example and a
bunch of other stuff AXYZ grid then like
all this stuff like just tons of
information here for you to kind of look
through and see what's available with
matplotlib another interesting aspect to
matplotlib is Seabourn it's kind of like
a add-on almost to matplotlib you can
basically download Seabourn and then at
like the top of your script just import
Seabourn and i think that's all you
actually have to do is just import the
seam the import Seabourn let me just
click this introduction real quick I
thought I could get configuring let me
just I'm just trying to get to like a
really basic example I'm pretty sure all
you did tend to need to do is just
import Seabourn as SNS or something
anyway you can kind of play around with
yeah yeah so as long as you just import
it I'm almost positive at will also act
a lot like a stylesheet for you too but
you can do a lot of really cool stuff
with Seaborn too and you again and they
have a gallery that you can kind of look
at and scroll through and be like wow I
really like that or whatever figure out
what you're kind of interested in doing
and then you can kind of you know copy
that code basically so that marks the
end of this tutorial series hopefully
you guys enjoyed if you have any
questions or comments please free leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time